this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] happy
labor day it's monday september 5th the
joint is brought to you by draftkings oh
[__] thursday night is it kick off to
another [__] nfl season and to
celebrate draftkings sportsbook the
official sports betting part of the nfl
is giving you a cut new customers a
tremendous [__] offer are you ready
for this right now new customers can bet
5 bucks and get 200 and big ones and
free bets instantly but wait there's
more draftkings wants everybody to
experience the thrill of early win
promotion so it's simple but on any team
to win
if you guys leave by 10 points at any
time during the game you get paid
instantly even if your team loses
this is completely [__] insane but
you're the crazy one if you don't get it
on the action
this [__] sunday or this thursday
download the draftking sports book app
now
use promo code joey to get 203 bets
instantly when you place five hours on
any football team
this [__] sunday that's called
joey only at draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting part of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details now
download the draftking sportsbook app
and let's get ready get laid paid and
pop [__] laid [__] the joint
is also brought to you by
cbd lion listen
my cat wasn't doing well i started
giving her a cbd tincture and she's
[__] in there jumping up and down cbd
lion has helped me in more ways than one
from my anxiety to my [__] knees
to now my cat's [__] life and
well-being i take the tincture every day
and i'm tip top magoo but don't take it
from me go to cbd line right now
download the third party lab results and
put your first order in i'm gonna get
you 20 off on your first [__]
order at cbd line pressing code joint
joey or church 20 off on your first
order of any cbd line it's the best cbd
out there
let's get this party started it's monday
the [__] fifth [__]
time for some cheeseburgers
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's up you bad [__] it's monday
happy labor day to all you [__]
the summer is officially over i don't
know you can't dress in white you know
you can't go to long island no more i
don't know what the [__] it is but it
doesn't matter i love the [__] summer
you know like i've been telling you guys
this is the best summer i've had in a
long time
but i [__] love the fall especially
listen there's two months of the year on
the east coast that are just tremendous
and that's [__] may
before the humidity shows up you don't
know what it's like to walk around the
city eating a slice of pizza with two
[__] bongos in you stop it you know
what i'm saying you can stop on a
quarter for one of those terrorists hot
dog the [__] sad brat with the
tremendous but
september is a [__] gorgeous month in
new york i don't know if you look at my
old schedules i always came to new york
in september because something about the
trees the [__] air
the weather it's 70 degrees today's a
[__] beautiful day to be a lot and
it's been beautiful the last uh 10 days
i couldn't believe we had softball
practice last week already so the year
is popping the reason why i like this
time of the year is because it's get
down
this is it this is whatever we [__]
around the rest of the year we jumped up
and down for eight months
we [__] uh you know told stories but
once september comes you gotta look at
what's going on for 2023 and go well for
me to have a successful 2023 i got to
kick this smaller file i love this time
of the year because it sets up
2023. think about it whatever you do now
you're doing for 2023 but pretty much if
you're
[__] painting a house whatever you're
setting up uh if you're a [__]
painter you're setting up you're taking
[__] bids and you're trying to pack
in all your indoor work for the winter
you know this is what people do this
time of the year for me i'm excited i'm
uh
12 days away from the residency at the
sony theater
tickets are sold out do not pay over 40
[__] dollars while stabbing the
goddamn neck
and that's it guys i mean
this is it
you know usually i'll take this week off
whatever for labor day you guys ain't
watching [__] but guess what [__] that
i'm so excited about the last quarter
we're kicking this [__] today
gold's
[__] the setting football season's
upon us you know that's the other thing
once you start smelling this time of
year you're like okay a lot of things
are [__] happening college football
last week now [__] pro football you
know in a couple more weeks we're going
into baseball playoffs it's just a
[__] great time of the year you know
what i'm saying
october is going to be [__] i love it
i love you know listen
i can sit here and tell you i'm a fan of
this guy i'm waiting on this list
ever since i moved to jersey i started
doing something on sundays
and i got to tell you something i look
forward to it all week
i go to jimmy florentine's house with
his little childhood buddies from the
old bridge
there's no must there's no fuss they
bring over a couple piece of pies
they bring over some beers and it's just
[__] guys watching football they're
not talking about golf
they're not talking about you know you
know how they raise their kids trust me
that's the farthest thing they talk
about they talk about they they say some
[__] tremendous [__]
not a lot of people couldn't sit in that
basement today i'm telling you right now
if you sat in that basement you know
at one point you're gonna go what the
[__] did he say or what did joey say
because i get in there too who gives a
[__] but it's just guys guys that i
never even knew i had been in la
with so many phony people for so [__]
long that i forgot what these guys were
like these just guys that are blue
collar guys they work all [__] week
they don't give a [__] about your
instagram they don't give a [__] about
how many friends you have on twitter
they don't give a [__] about none of
that [__]
they just want to get their beers get
away from their wives and watch three
[__] football games on the sun then i
don't [__] blame them they work
[__] hard but i had never experienced
that since i left here like maybe in
colorado working for the sports betting
people on monday nights we used to get
together and watch football and get
beers and [__] and listen guys i don't
drink i go for the wings i eat a couple
[__] wings a slice of pizza but just
to be out with a bunch of guys and [__]
like that it's always great i don't even
like
i can't go to a bar i can't sit in a bar
i don't drink so i'm like the odd man
[__] what i'm gonna do sit there and
drink coke with a lemon in it how much
of a [__] hypocrite am i so i just
don't go to [__] bars but if you
invite me to your house i could bring a
little tootsie roots
i could eat my edibles i can get a slice
of pizza usually i show up with carlos
and get myself an extra cheese with
[__] meatball
extra crispy and i bring it over there
the [__] pie weighs 30 goddamn pounds
so i'm looking forward to that [__] and
like i told you [__] last week
listen guys i know a lot of you guys
were other draft sites or whatever
having a great time
listen man
draftkings i've been with them for what
three years now two years two and a half
years a little bit before the pandemic
like i had tried other sites out but
draftkings just grabbed me the thing
about draftkings that felt good was i
felt
i could trust them like i wasn't going
to wake up in the morning and my money
was going to be gone whether it's 200 or
you don't want to get [__] beat so i
always trusted them for that you know
like i've had a couple friends that i
was in florida and i signed up for a
local sports thing and it takes them a
month to pay me back all that [__]
doesn't fly with me either guys i'm the
type of [__] i put a bet in
i either pay you or i skip town you know
what i'm saying then what and with
draftkings you can't skip [__] town
you know so i i don't know who you were
with or whatever but do yourself a favor
go to the draftking sports book download
put my name in and guys just put joey
not the whole [__] name not
[__] it's not gonna react but
they're just gonna call the cops on your
ass but if it's you know if you're into
football just to have fun listen i'm not
here
i'm reading these articles lately about
sports gambling how people getting
hooked on [__] first off
when i was a kid
you could really get hooked because you
just had a guy on the phone
he doesn't know what's in my wallet mike
doesn't know what i have in my wallet
mike doesn't know
what happened was no atm cards back then
he doesn't know what i have in my bank
account
so i could just call mike and go it's
this easy
today i like uh
i don't know
[__] buffalo bills on thursday night
and michael go what do you want to bet
him for now
if i make 300 a [__] week
you know
i'm betting this for
uh 25 bucks for entertainment so i can
watch the game and yell a little bit
throw a shoe with the cat whatever the
[__] is going on
but sometimes you go you know what man
i'm good at this i'm going to make some
[__] money at this
like i did when i was 18. i'm i'm good
at this i could pick these winners and
also you bet over your head
so i could just tell mike hey i got 500
in the game that game loses
i gotta work [__] three weeks and
overtime to pay that [__] 500. that's
not gonna happen so what do i do i bet
another five [__] hundred
on the and it loses again now i'm down
to small 1200.
now comes monday night football i gotta
bet the farm i lose i'm down four
thousand dollars i can suck 200 dicks
and work 3 000 part-time job hours i'm
not gonna be able to pay this [__]
guy
this is why i like draftkings they know
what you got
you put your atm card down you got a
hundred bucks they don't take over 100
bucks so
it lets you bet at what you afford like
what you can afford you know listen guys
i could [__] bet those games for 2003
it'd be a big shot oh
guys it's entertainment i don't want to
get in trouble
and i know this going in so what do you
do today they have a thing saturday they
had a great [__] deal they had like
oklahoma to win
ohio state and alabama to win by 42
[__] points
now what are the chances of all these
three teams it
you put 10 bucks on that you win 180
dollars
that's not bad
so if you enter two of those [__]
pools maybe put 15 on the team or
if you could pull out 200 miles on a
[__] weekend that's why i like
draftkings because they have a ton of
trap uh prop bets listen oh shawnee the
[__] japanese pitch is the best
player in the [__]
in baseball but he plays for [__]
angels that are clippers of los angeles
you know i'm saying the clippers and the
angels are the exact same thing they're
going to have 200 great people and
they're never going to win who gods
right so
when you bet the angels i don't bet the
[__] angels will know shawnee's [__]
they're probably going to get sheltered
but
you know that [__] japanese
dude's gonna hit a home run or three
singles so i usually
bet you know ten bucks for shoddy to hit
over point half a half a point single
if you bet that ten times you're not
going to lose oh shani always hit the
[__] he just hit 30 [__] home runs
he's the first japanese player to have
30 home runs and win 10 [__] games
pitching how do you think you're dealing
with joey bananas i don't follow too
many people but i like shoshone ortani
anyway my point is
it's draftking season give him a [__]
shot i don't know who you've been with i
don't know what you've been doing but i
tell you what i have a great time on
that i haven't refilled my account
and maybe
i refilled it
for the nc for march for march madness i
haven't put money in there since march
madness
i play with the same twenty dollars five
dollars
some nights i'm bored i play five hands
a casino whatever blackjack [__] a
dollar a dollar and that's it i go to
[__] bed
you know i understand like people get
addicted to different [__] things
but with draftkings any of those other
sites that are all very [__] good and
trustworthy
i can't see myself getting in trouble so
if i talk about draftkings thursday
night [__] football the buffalo
goddamn bills
at the [__] la rams oh [__] i love
the bills this year i don't know if
they're gonna [__] win the
championship but they're gonna win some
games stay on top of them watch
indianapolis i love a [__] lotta i'm
way better with football than i am with
anything else and i'll still just bet 25
[__] bucks just to [__] go over to
jimmy's and yell and scream you know
they're in miami dolphin house so i'll
go over there
i always bet 25 bucks on the dolphins
just because i'm sitting there i'm
eating that [__] food i can't go over
that bed against the dolphins there
[__] dolphin house where's your
respect i'm sucking
liquid iv the [__] cherry oh my
goodness
what flavor is this this is [__]
delicious
i don't even know what the [__] it is i
can't see without my beautiful glasses
oh [__] this is golden cherry tremendous
guys just [__] tremendous
16 ounces ba-boom it's a whole different
operation
talking about [__] nick saban talking
about football
i thought my [__] i thought i'd kill
somebody thursday night
i thought i [__] stabbed somebody 10
times thursday night i had text messages
my phone was ringing i was outside
talking to the neighbors and i come in
it's like 9 30 at night and people like
dawg nick saban was talking about you
did you see this [__] right on the espn
or something there was a game
so i'm like nick saban
i'm like what the [__] i go nick saban
alabama
and they're like yeah hurry up go on
youtube people posted it to your page
you didn't say it mike so
like i don't [__] know nick saban he
don't [__] shout me out unless he
came to a comedy show that dude's a
christian he [__] hates guys like me
you know what i'm saying i'm a fan of
his i love [__] nick saban sabon
whatever the [__] you want to call him
so i go online and right away he's
talking to speech about [__] what's
gonna happen and he goes don't tell me
about what happened last year
tell me about what's gonna go on today
the church of what's happening now and
all this [__] and people are [__]
like i must have got 20 retweets of the
video you know people were saying
no he didn't [__] know if he [__]
had people hitting him up today put your
apologies that church of what's
happening now they're no good
they did drugs they killed the whole
bedroom and they [__] you know
they [__] up people
get the [__] your name off there he
didn't know guys i mean it's it's
yeah no
no i don't i've never met that man i'm a
fan of his i would go to one of his
games i i love alabama but that's not it
but it's funny that
the text that he uses the context that
he listen let's get to the basic of this
[__] church of what's happening now
first time i heard a church what's
happening now i was mercy's age
i was [__] mercy's age it was called
the church it was a sketch that flip
wilson did on his show every week it was
called the church what's happening now i
don't remember what it was about i left
the lighting and tell you i knew
when i did the church what's happening
now people reached out to me and they
said flip wilson might sue you
for taking that that name or whatever
and i'm like listening 30 years ago
it was the name of a sketch
and that's all you know it was just the
name of sketch the church or what's
happened now so you're like [__]
eight or nine you're like what's
happening now i don't know what the [__]
that means that word didn't come back
into my life
until i was about
24 25 years old and it's so weird that
i had spoken to erica florentine last
week and i go erica and i have another
idea for a book
and she goes what are you talking about
and i go listen erica
i'm sitting here now not remember i was
talking about being like vengeful
regrets and [__] like that i'm like you
know when we wrote that book
we had a great d we had a great [__]
uh
you know outline we had a great outline
we did it and then we had an outside
agent do it for us
on everything that he had listened to
over the years and we we met in the
middle
and it was great i think we did a great
job we were very thorough
we took our time you know there was no
[__] uh
fluff in there
we gave you some extra stories that you
had never heard in the podcast and stuff
but ever since i locked the book up in
february and i submitted it you know you
just think of [__] when i go to an
audition
i always on in the car as soon as you
get in the car you're like [__] i should
have done that but i should have done
this should we go to a p for a slice of
pizza and you go and you eat two slices
on the way out you're like [__] i should
have had the stuffed peppers with the
prosciutto or whatever you know what
happens you always think of something
on the way out after you've done it
already so
after we did the book you know the last
couple of months i'm like [__] i forgot
to mention that in the book or
i shouldn't have spoken too much about
this in the book or whatever you just
it's not regrets it's just uh
things you wish you would have put in
there
so
i'm thinking about uh
the other day i'm thinking about
somebody had put in a book like a friend
of mine
in fact it was because it was my
brother-in-law's my sister-in-law's
three anniversary
of passing which was friday god rest her
soul
and i was thinking about how much her
and my friend daniel rhaego did for me
in 199 i was just sitting there one
night i was watching tv and you know
sometimes you're watching tv and you
just [__] drift off thinking about
something stupid or whatever
uh
so
i was just thinking about how much if
people knew
how much these two people had helped me
in 93 like nobody would even [__]
know
like between darren and uh
sherry running
sherry ronnie was basically financing my
comedy career with 20s and 30s and do
you have money on you show me the money
show me your money and not come on
sherry put 20 bucks in here so you're
not out there without money and then i
had a friend darren
who guys this guy was a [__] savage
with three hands
and he would call me and go what are we
doing today what club am i taking it and
i'm like what are you talking about
and yes we were both addicts
and uh he knew i would always be half or
whatever we bought with coke but no
these guys had my [__] back and they
would
push and push and push so
i called sherry uh
erica florentine the next thing they go
erika
i really think i wanna
i'm not saying nothing bad i go i just
feel that
i didn't
talk about because there was so much
material
i didn't talk about certain people like
i wanted to
like there were a lot of people i just
wanted to
describe in the book as angels
like
you know dan rhaego and sherry ronnie
are both past god rest both their souls
you know darren lasted till
which probably put him at you know
[__] uh what was i 30 something
when he passed away and sherry ronnie
passed away two years ago you know but
it's just so
they were angels in my life that came
and went in the [__] night you know
anthony bonzano
was a [__] angel that came into my
life when i first moved to jersey and he
showed me around
and he made sure people didn't [__] with
me then he brought me into his house and
introduced me to his family and he
[__] went out in the night and i
[__] slipped him to his spot
dominic speciale same thing you know and
they don't didn't all die all these
people didn't die they were they came
into my life into a
in a certain point in my life to make
that uh
point in my life a lot more bearable as
i could say you know and i think about
them all the time
and i think they deserve a lot of credit
and nobody will never even know their
[__] names you know so when i saw
that uh
you know nick saban had had said that
and i started thinking about
[__] uh the book
you know when he said church or what's
happening now it's so weird i was
one of the biggest highlights of my life
i feel one of the best things i ever did
in my life
and it was sometimes you do good things
without even knowing
sometimes you make good choices without
even [__] knowing you made them you
you'll see later on down the road you're
like that was a good [__] choice i
made i mean
i made a lot of bad choices right i did
a lot of [__] up things
but i was detailing cars i was making
800 [__] dollars a month
i was working you know
60 hours of [__] week and
i got promoted to a detail i started off
as a shagger and i got promoted to a
detail and then when i was making
uh money i was making great money
but i was busting my [__] hump for
this morning i was coming home smelling
like [__] chemicals and
breathing in chemicals and it just and
every time i drop off a car to build
crowd subaru the [__] manager would
always say yo
what the [__] are you doing bro you're a
street guy you know how to talk to
people got the gift again you're in a
[__] car steaming engines get your
light together stupid come on over and
you know sell some cars was like
for years people been bugging me to
[__] sell cars i don't want to
[__] sell cars come on come on every
time every two days i have to go with a
drop off a car joey please go get a
shirt next time
and there was just no [__] way
finally i was like
i want to do more things in my life yeah
i'm making a grand a week i'm 24 years
old
i'm bringing home about 7.50
but this ain't getting me [__] this is
my rent this is my [__]
school books some shoes and
i can't fit cocaine into this budget i
got i got to make more money if i want
to snort coke if you want to play the
game
you know and i was looking not to be a
[__] thief i was looking just to be a
decent person so
i asked him one day how much can i make
in here and he's like you can make
anywhere from
three to [__] ten thousand dollars a
month you know you can write your own
ticket
and uh
i said all right on one monday i [__]
took the gig and
i told them
i would come in on a saturday
and give it a shot on a saturday because
i didn't want to get fired from my
detail in jail i mean i couldn't do
anything else i was going to eat in
boulder they have a thousand jobs
that'll get you through
but they have like four of them that you
can actually get ahead with you know i'm
saying like there's college jobs and
[__] like that's a job you get ahead
with you know if i was making a thousand
dollars at 52 000 a year in 1987 that's
a lot of [__] loot for [__]
washing cars
but this guy's telling me i can make
more [__] cash so i'm like dog i
don't believe you
peter pinto you know i don't [__]
believe you
he went that was a guy's name peter
pinto he went he got everybody else that
worked there and one guy's name was jim
wheeler my heart ended up [__] being
one of the most influential people in my
life
and this other guy called wayne means
but the whole three of them clicked
together peter pinto was a little weird
jim wheeler was my type of salesman very
honest and very direct but for some
reason wayne means used to motivate
the [__] out of me this guy was just and
the owner of that bill crouch subaru at
the time yes
bill crouch's name was on the thing but
the money from that thing was this
[__] dude the whitest dude ever
but cool as [__] he was something to do
with the government he was in the
service and all this [__] tough dude and
he used to call me the [__] renegade
the renegade joey your [__] renegade
so you know the first saturday i went in
i sold three [__] cars
and i'd call the detail and go shove
your [__] water hose up your ass
papa's cleaned his last goddamn car and
i went to bill crouch subaru had a ball
five i'd have bought my friend's mom's
credit card and to buy three [__]
jackets with white shirts and you know
and i uh
got a job over there not knowing what i
was doing and
yeah jim wheeler was training me in the
art of sales like you know
the steps
taking them selling your feet clothes on
your ass
all these little [__] sayings but
there was one dude wayne means that
every morning
he would [__] drill me to death and
he was laughing like he was a he was a
funny dude first off he was a biker not
a [__] not one of these dudes that
you see with six fat [__] on a saturday
on the turnpike you know okay okay you
know no this guy was a straight up
gangster
biker okay this [__] let his
hair long
tattoos before tattoos were cool you
know the whole [__] deal
so to make a living and for his wife
he was married and he would come home
for six months of the year this guy was
cool as [__]
he had a deal with his wife he had step
kids so he really was he married her
later after she got divorced he kind of
raised the kids but not really and he
had a sister and a boy
dave is in florida doing 30 of the life
right now i'm surprised i didn't put him
under the chair right his son dave
anyway
uh wayne was just a [__] one of those
dude i was 25
i was wild and he knew how to reel me in
but he also knew how to motivate me
so when i would come in the morning he'd
come over to the car how are you doing
today joey all right what's going on
with your brother you're looking good
hey let me do yourself a favor shine
that [__] shoe that's the first
people look at it
when they walk in as your [__] shoes
so what good is it i have the nice suit
on ironed if your shoes are not going to
be [__]
shine come on shine your [__] shoes
how are you going to buy a 10 000 car
from somebody with a 10 presentation
this guy was just money and he didn't
talk to me like
uh white privilege he spoke to me like a
[__] street guy you know all those
things i yelled over the years on
periscope and [__] i was just
emulating him that's all i was doing
you know like when people came up to him
and said but wayne i sold three cars
yesterday yeah but that was yesterday
we're talking about today the church of
what's happening now what's going on
today who do you have a car to sell to
so he always he taught me how to [__]
uh
narrow it down to today he was sharp
and there was times i'd bring him
customers
this guy would give them a tremendous
ear beat he knew how to give you an ear
beating for you to buy a car
you know like when somebody's giving you
a beating and he
they're like you know what just give me
the paperwork because i can't take this
airbeat no more i'll sign the paperwork
before i take another minute of this
[__] ear beat and i'll never forget i
was selling the car one day
and on a car like in today's market
you know you have an msrp okay it was a
new car it was right in the showroom
it was a subaru i never forget this
the people come over
and i go yeah
because in meetings
wayne means knew how to make money on a
car deal some people know how to sell a
car
wayne means knew how to set you up to
make money
so most people start with an msrp
this is 1987. wayne means is still
starting with a [__] addendum for
people who don't know what an addendum
is
msrp is the sticker ford or subaru or
cadillac or mitsubishi or toyota puts on
the window with what's on the car what
packages they have
and what's the estimated deal of price
but then next to it there's always an
addendum and that addendum costs the
dealer 15 [__] cents it's a piece of
paper with a piece of ink on it it says
you know uh white wall tires
uh on the car it just has a bunch of
[__]
rust
protection
window protection all this [__] and they
plop on another 2 500 and it's just air
but in wayne means mind he goes i want
you to start from that price because if
they have a trade-in i could give them
more money off the trading from that
addendum that's 2500 worth of air but to
anybody who knows anybody who's a
gangster and does
mur and does research before they go buy
a car you look at the [__] addendum
and go [__] that i'm not even talking to
you about that we're starting here
so you know it's when it takes so i'm
going to show them with this guy he's a
bolder guy he's [__] a genius
and
this guy is like i'm not even starting
there so don't even talk about that i go
the car starts there because that's how
you get gross gross is the amount of
profit you're gonna make to that card
deal so i'm starting from [__] gross
i'm like no you gotta pay attention guys
like
i'm not gonna pay that i start here
wayne means pops out from the desk it
was a little higher desk he could hear
everything and he goes sir have you ever
heard of the dendomac the 1969 listen
there was never an addendum act of 1969.
nobody even had an act in 19 [__] 69
but wayne means proceed them to tell
them
about the addendum act of
1979 or 69 and the senators that were
behind it you know the guy bought the
car at [__] addendum
there was no [__] addendum there was
no [__]
act of 1969.
it was the ear beating he gave them
about the addendum that the people said
all right [__] we'll just pay for it i
think i ended up making like 3200 on
that car on one [__] car usually you
make like a thousand bucks 800
400 i made 3200 profit it was like a
four it was like a subaru
the gl10
a lot of people don't remember the gl10
for some old subaru people that's the
[__] subaru that you press the button
and the tires are raised
so if you're driving and there's more
and like you're coming off a highway and
you're turning into the hills but
the mountain hasn't been shoveled it's
been like plowed but not really shoveled
they're still like two or three feet you
would press a button and you stopped the
car and the car would rise not like
those mexican [__] things that bounce
up and down
i'm talking about
the car would just rise up the whole
suspension
and you would [__] drive through
wayne means was great because his gang
of motorcycle people i think sold speed
and he didn't do
he didn't do drugs like they did crack
in those days they moved crack across
the [__] country
i can't say what gang he was in because
he killed me i don't even know if he's
alive
we probably spoke uh
eight years ago he was running a car
dealership
in las vegas and we spoke on the phone
and uh
we're going to try to meet him come to
his show he was very proud of me he said
he saw me in some movies and [__]
but wayne did not do powder and he did
not do any of that [__]
but and wayne didn't care if you did it
he just wanted you to be such a good
salesman
they didn't want you to do it in the
daytime
i keep telling me if you want to go
smoke pot that's your decision i can't
stop you but joey
you'd be a lot better and a lot more
focused if you didn't do that [__]
i never [__] listened to him you know
i would go out there and get high and
come back and i could tell he would be
upset so i eventually i stopped doing
all that [__]
but after about two months of working
there with him
he would every he would always go on a
tangent about coke he was just one of
those guys that if you even said i'm
getting the [__] out of here i'm getting
an eight ball of coke [__] you you're
just gonna make your mind mush and all
this [__] he would just he would just
say all this [__] to you
so he hated vinegar
he [__] hated the smell of vinegar
right
so i would [__] uh
get a bottle of white vinegar
and i would get those little [__]
cups that people put water in at the
water station
and i would pull vinegar
and i would put vinegar in the car in
the corners of his office one on one
corn i'd hide and one on the other
corner and i waited for him to come and
i'd be sitting in his office i'd see him
pull up and i'd sit in his office and
like with a fake uh with a fake [__]
question
and he would come in hang his jacket up
joey i'm not here ten minutes what is it
and i go nothing man i gotta ask you a
question about the delivery on this car
i would just
[__] and he would go like this while
i was talking to him what and he would
go
he goes you smell vinegar i smell
vinegar i can't be here there's vinegar
and he would go all around i smelled
vinegar i smelled vinegar and this went
on so me and one of the other salesmen
run on it so i knew he would go from one
office to the coffee office i would hide
vinegar right by the coffee machine so i
put coffee because he would go right in
there and make a coffee the vinegar was
on the side he went in there he's like i
can't i can't even make coffee i did
this to him once a [__] week with the
vinegar and he'd have to leave after
about two months he figured out
somebody was [__] with him right so
that was one thing i did too
the other thing i do with him i get a
fishing line with a fishing hook and i
get a white piece of paper and i'd make
a bundle a cocaine bindle and i'd put
the fishing hook tiny little fishing
hook at the end of the bindle and i
would throw the fish i would throw them
i would throw this and he'd be sitting
at his desk it was a tower you know so
the the new car manager sits here the
used car manages it's like three feet on
them and he could see the floor i would
make the bindle big
you know and
it was like [__] i dream of gene
listen i dream of genie is a show about
a [__] it's not about a genie and
it's not about the astronaut it's about
the torture they inflict on major healy
whatever his [__] name is the
professor the professor
it's the the torture they inflict on him
i've always loved that about a show and
i've always loved that about life so
i would put the fishing hook with the
half gram of coke with nothing in the
thing it was just a bindle and i would
lay it out where he would see it
and he would [__] get up off his
chair and walk down and i would have the
fishing line i'd pull it away right and
he would come he'd be looking for the
bundle i knew i saw it i knew i [__]
saw it somebody's playing with me so i
would do that to him and then actually
get bindles and put like talcum powder
in it and just throw it on the floor and
he would pick him up and open them and
go
because i have your attention please
somebody's snorting coke here and he
would give you a 20-minute lecture on
the evils of cocaine and what's going to
happen to you if you snort coke and all
this [__]
but this was him but his
i learned a lot from him like he was
this was after carmine balzano this was
after a lot of things in my life
and i navigated towards him every day in
those months when i was having 16
14 12 car months you know it was because
i was listening to him
to a t
it's everything else he did
while being a salesman and the one thing
i took him is if you're going to be a
salesman you gotta look [__] sharp
your shoes have to be shine your socks
gotta match
you can't [__] stink
you know you have to have a nice tie
when you know he taught me that you have
to speak to women when they come talk to
you like when a couple comes talk you
have to talk to a woman because a woman
makes 80 percent of the buying decision
in a [__] family
this guy was just uh
he was just my angel
that's why i want to put them in the
book and it don't [__] stop there
because remember i stayed at bill crowd
subaru for about [__] six months and
then i got to an argument with them and
somebody pissed on my leg and i thought
that i could make money
somewhere else so i left and went to
chrysler and i was at chrysler for about
six months and i would always stay in
touch with him he was like a father
figure
and then one day i just called him i
said listen i gotta start making some
real dough again
i'm not making money in chrysler and i
went back there and maybe
seven weeks later eight weeks later i
got arrested for the kidnapping and
nobody
nobody was more heartbroken about that
kidnapping
than that dude but let me tell you what
transpired with that [__] kidnapping
you know i did the kidnapping on the
[__] tuesday i had the day off from
work
and they caught the guy tuesday night
with him in the trunk of the car and
they immediately set a [__] they came
looking for me
now they couldn't really find me uh my
license had my in-laws address on it and
you know i i don't know who the [__]
knows they just wanted to get a definite
search on me
so
that morning when they woke up they did
some snooping and they found that i
worked at bill crowd subaru
so they went to bill crowd subaru
that morning i was [__] coming down
off that battery acid like a
[__] cat tranquilizer whatever
the [__] i was doing that night and
blazing brett hazen the detailer there
came and [__]
banged up my glass he's like hey
the cops are at the dealership they're
looking for you they're about to come
over here
you know so i got ready and [__] like
that and i go how much time do i have
and he goes
well he goes they were still set when i
left and wayne means
would not give him your address
i'm like what and he's like wayne means
his [__]
telling he looked at longmont and all
this [__] just to give you more
time and i was like [__]
wayne did that for me i'm like gee and i
did what i had to do that morning but at
some point
you know there were no cell phones then
so i had to call wayne at the subaru
dealership and go
you know thank you for what you did he
goes listen we can't talk long
i mean he was slicker than [__] he goes
hey we can't talk long in case they have
the phone
uh tap i don't think they have it
goes you never know
he goes call me at my wife's number you
know the number over there and i'll
be you know i'll help you as much as i
[__] can't and at the time like i
said
this guy didn't do drugs this guy didn't
uh
drink
you know he was a biker and he did what
he did as a bike you know they take care
of business they they beat people up and
they transport i don't know what he was
doing but
i'm gonna tell you something else that
years later i saw him i didn't go back
to work for him but i would stop there
from day to day
and he always felt
very guilty
because he had hired
velar back at that dealership so he
always thought that i was going to come
back to work and be great
but if vella wasn't there i wouldn't
have gotten and he said he goes it
really wasn't me who hired
kent vella back he goes i i kept my nose
out of it i didn't care one way or the
other he goes it was the used car
manager and the f and i guy that wanted
him back on the [__] lot because they
thought he could sell but he goes i know
he came back with a lot of [__]
problems and look what happened he ended
up taking you down i was like he didn't
take me down
i don't ever want you to think that i
was a victim in this thing i took him
down you know
but after uh
that morning when the cops were looking
for me
he wouldn't give him my [__] address
at all and then they they called
the dealership where i worked at before
the chrysler dealership
and that's who gave my [__] address
but wayne means
was a [__] soldier to the end you
understand me
yeah he was a church [__] sheldon
that's what he used to say all the time
he used to go hey brother come on what
are we doing today the church or what's
happened that's what the church what's
happened now
came from i know we ended up talking
about other older stories and [__]
because we thought we were going to be a
news outlet at first like i like you
know i don't [__] know anything about
the news
but it was more to you know with the
church what's happening now what's going
on you know it was a church and it's a
state of [__] mind
you know and i still live off that
[__] state of mind it's [__] today
i don't you know people call me for
[__] audition like when i was on
north carolina and people call me for
the audition it's like you got to put it
on tape monday okay it's [__]
wednesday got nothing to do with me it's
got nothing to do with me you know what
i'm saying the church of what's
happening now is the church of what's
happened now but i think about wayne
means you know and that guy is
definitely
i'm definitely gonna put him in that
book of angels because
after i saw the [__] thing and i
you know uh
saw the
saban [__] thing
i put his name in the list because i'm
only gonna have 10 people you know it's
so weird
how many notes i had made about him it
was like
you ever have a boss that really isn't
your boss
like he's your boss but
now he's your boss but he
talks to you more
like he you know he'll have you either
way or whatever like this guy knew i was
a good salesman he knew i was dependable
he knew i could count on me i was honest
you know
he knew about some of the [__] i was
doing he never held it against me
when i when i got in trouble for the
kidnapping i'm sure i let him down
but i'm sure at the same time uh
you know he knew i was young and stuff
if i was
24 25 when i was hanging around wayne
wayne had to be around 50 55. good
looking white dude
blue eyes he always wore like off-color
sunglasses
and his hair was greased back slick like
[__] the coach of the lakers with the
white streaks on him and [__]
he was tough
he was warm
he would talk to you like when i said to
you before about the addendum some
people would listen to that as a [__]
lie like well the guy lied to somebody
during the summer call no he didn't
that dude was too stupid to check out
the [__] what the guy was talking
about
you know
i'm sure that once yeah google it you
know at that time there was no google
but
guy was an astronaut you know he should
have known better but what i'm saying is
he was very honest with people and one
thing i liked about him was if he
couldn't close you go let me ask you a
question
what do you think is fair for me to sell
you this car
what kind first off is it all is it okay
for me to make a profit like i liked it
you know this this people's approach of
salesmanship that's not really
salesmanship it's trickery
he trained me not to be a trickster he
trained me
to be a salesman and to sell them the
car
knowing that they're going to come back
or refer somebody to me
so that's what i liked about him so like
if you came in and you were all confused
he'd call a timeout he'd even pull it up
and go timeout let's start this again
what do you want the person would say it
and then he would go okay this is what i
could do
let me ask you a question is it okay for
me to make a profit
and the people go oh yes of course i
mean we're here we do advertising i got
to pay the salesman i got to pay the
mechanic i got to pay the guy that
washes your car so is it okay if we
[__] make a problem the people go
yeah
and then he would go okay let's do this
and he would go get the [__] invoice
he would go rip the invoice out of the
book and put it down and go
what is the fair profit for me to make
that's pretty great and the people go
800 and he'd go give me a thousand and
we'll do the deal right now
this is what it's gonna look on monthly
payments
this is your down payment and then he
would talk to people
he would go going i want you to think
about this
you got two kids
you're buying this car you're putting
five thousand dollars down this is the
guy that taught me all this [__] i used
to just copy him and close people
because that's the clothes i liked i
don't want you to feel like i'm robbing
you
so he goes you're giving me five
thousand dollars
and this is 1987 guys and this is before
the
the great crash of 87. he would go
listen
how much you give me five thousand
dollars scrap that
if you give me twenty five hundred
dollars if you give me five thousand
dollar down payment
you're
you're uh
financing for 80 48 months is before 60
month financing he goes you're
negotiating for 48 months and
your payment will be you know 310. can
you afford that people like yeah that's
great okay
let's do one better
how about you give me
twenty five hundred dollars down you
take that other twenty five hundred
dollar and put in your son's [__]
college fund and take the other [__]
2500 down
put that down and why don't we lease the
car and your payment will be 198.
instead of 310 a month
i'll save you 110 a month and the people
would [__] go what are you talking
about i don't want to lease a car i need
to go well when you own that car when
you finance it you don't own it
so for 48 months you're not gonna own
that car
the title the bank has the title you're
gonna pay 198 a month
you're not gonna have the title and at
the end of three years you can just
bring this [__] car back and i'll
give you a brand new one for 208 a month
with nothing down
because with subaru that's it the down
payment keeps transferring it's a
[__] no brand and some people that
it's a great deal and then he would tell
him listen
you lease
what depreciates and you own
what appreciates
a car don't appreciate you know they
tell you it will subarus hold that
valley there's some cars that hold their
value
but you know and it made sense to me and
that's where i got my sales pitch from
that's why i always sold like that and
that sales pitch went on me
for years i would tell that's why that's
how i negot you know
down payment is profit
down payment is profit so i used to flip
that around guys
i would
try to sell all my tickets out
sunday night
before the weekend i would always try to
do that
because i always felt like if i had to
go to that the more tickets i sold
by the time till i got to the town i
didn't want to do radio
so i called it like down payment if i
sold all my tickets before i had to get
there wednesday
no so even if i [__] went to a comedy
club and i'd get there on a thursday on
a wednesday night
because they wanted me to do radio
thursday wednesday i made sure and i
copied this from joe rogan i made sure
that i went to the best
restaurant in town and left a good tip
and the next morning when you wake up
all your tickets are sold out because
the staff from that restaurant goes out
to all the bars afterwards and they tell
everybody your [__] business that you
were there with four people you got high
plus you gave them 100 tip on a [__]
80 dollar tab and the ticket sell out it
was just and so i always stole that
thinking that down payment equivalents
anyway i don't know if anybody else will
get it but
yeah wayne means is [__] great so
when i heard that from nick saban it was
just like uh
it was like a uh
i don't know it was just great what's
that
it was just like a big flashback guys
and it's great
i love uh i really want to do this book
about
you know and it's people who would you
would least expect you know
people goes rogan going to be in there
is paul moore going to be in there his
people that like when i looked at the
comedy people i'm going to put in there
i got to be honest here there were a lot
of comics that came through my life that
helped me out people you would never
dream of
people you've never heard of the most
help i got were not from famous comics
it was from people
during my open mic days during my
feature days in seattle people who just
made little gestures and [__] like that
but the only person i am going to put in
there for
angels is something like mitchy sure you
know but we'll get to that later but
yeah i just uh wanted to get the
the church or what's happening that
story after you
because a lot of people didn't [__]
know it like a lot of people would still
hit me up over the weekend we'd just
steal it from i didn't steal it from
nobody
that was an old [__] uh
whatever thing and
when i decided we needed a name for the
podcast i had always been using it
i had always been using it for the last
like those last couple years in l.a when
an agent would call me and go yeah
i talked to a producer he's gonna have
an audition for you in three weeks come
on guys this is the church what's
happening now today what do we got going
on
[__] today you know what i'm
saying
so that's where i'm at guys on a
beautiful [__] monday i just want to
come on here today and tell you
i haven't been this excited about a fall
or a comedy show
in a long goddamn time i'm we got a dj
for september 17th we got a dj
for all the [__] shows uh
i'm happy we're in new york city for a
change
i got these two shows in jersey this
week on wednesday and thursday and then
we're shifting everything to [__] new
york city for the next six months that
i'll keep you guys posted for the
tickets for uh philadelphia for parks
casino the night before the 20th are you
going mike to that one
okay that one you go to
all these okay we'll get you clearance
all right cause i know mikey got the
kids it's [__] tough people with kids
it's tough it's a tough life man so
i'm sorry mike can't be a lot of the
gigs but [__] we try to get them to what
we can
you know but uh beside that i'm excited
about this fall i got my goals written
down
i'm gonna try to get a little healthier
try to get uh lose some for gain some
weight i don't need to gain no [__]
weight
uh try to lose some weight get a little
better with jujitsu i
tried to call rob before the podcast to
see how he done over the weekend
i appreciate that a lot of you guys
enjoyed that podcast a lot of you people
reached out to rob
you reached out to gabby uh
this was great podcast i love having him
on here because uh he reminded me of
what like i forgot i forgot all that
[__]
uh that we even did a podcast about it
he did like a segment on it about what
it took to be a [__] comic and once i
met him i'm like this [__] is a
sharp dude we got to get him up here so
that's it and that's that i love you
[__] with all you my heart
do not forget to download the draftking
sportsbook app it's opening day weekend
but [__] you got to be ready now
because thursday night it's buffalo
against the los angeles rams and we got
ufc next week we got a big [__]
weekend i want you guys to be prepared
but that's it and that's that i love
your [__] suckers with all my heart stay
black
and here's for a word for my
[__] sponsor jack
all right i want to thank you guys on a
monday thank you for taking my [__]
ear beating
but it's labor day i had to kick it off
i couldn't just leave you there hanging
off day the joint is brought to you by
cbd lion they're back [__] and
better than ever
from the gummies to the back walls to
the [__]
the gel caps listen you can live like a
[__] doctor
to help you with pain anxiety whatever
the [__] you got going through but don't
take it from me go to cbd lion read
read the third party lab results and how
this product works if you think there's
something you want to try whether it's
the hemp
whether it's the electronic cigarettes
or the cb
listen put your name in
joey joint or church and get 20 off your
first order do me a favor read up on
this you do need some cbd and cbd line
is what you need
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings oh my [__] god thursday
night
is [__] nfl
season is upon us
to celebrate draft king sportsbook an
official sports betting part of the nfl
is giving new customers a tremendous
deal are you ready for this right now
new customers you're gonna bet five
bucks and get 200 big ones and free bets
instantly and there's more draftking
wants everybody to experience the thrill
of [__] early win
you ready
this is completely insane but you're the
crazy one if you don't get in on it if
you guys lead by 10 points any time
during the game you get paid instantly
even if your team loses so do me a favor
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code joey to get 203 bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet on any football game this sunday
that's code joey j-o-e-y
only at draftking sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
draftkings download the app and now
let's go win some [__] money i
want to thank draftkings i want to thank
cbd lion and i want to thank you [__]
have a great labor day and i'll see you
wednesday morning dip dot magoo
[Music]
you